i've like completely just went silent on
social media because i
feel so
taken advantage i just feel so
dirty from it all that i just don't want
any part so i'd rather be invisible
naked and intimate images of a las vegas
woman shared hundreds of times on social
media police say her former boyfriend
violated our state's revenge porn law
and did that get her any justice well
it's a case our eight news now i-team
started following nearly two years ago
and tonight the victim is speaking
exclusively with our david charns saying
her reputation is ruined while her
ex-boyfriend gets a slap on the wrist
donald amick leaves court with a year of
probation in an order to stay off social
media i will never be the person that i
was before but this woman who's asked us
to hide her face says she's sentenced
for life i will never i never have that
secure feeling a life without privacy
because of the naked photos amick posted
of her online how many photos and videos
do you think there were
thousands she brought that claim to
police who say they found hundreds of
images shared without consent this
report obtained by the 8 news now i-team
says amick not only took nude
photographs and videos but posed as his
ex-girlfriend under the name of ashley
messaging random men and sending them
her nude photographs
you
have an underlying trust that nothing
will happen
in all according to court documents
police suspected amick shared hundreds
of nude and private photos of her alone
48 images where her face was quote
readily identifiable with 48 images they
suggested 48 charges of unlawful
dissemination of an intimate image
that's 48 felonies there was just so
many
accounts
fake people he pretended to be
metro police filed a warrant for amick's
arrest in february 2021 under nevada's
revenge porn law police picking him up
in his home state of missouri that april
by then the charges were reduced to five
counts of unlawful dissemination of an
intimate image a judge initially setting
bail at five thousand dollars but later
agreed to let amit go on his own
recognizance while awaiting his trial
amick's ex-girlfriend says she received
phone calls from random men and escort
companies
working in the service industry she
feared being alone in a room with a
stranger because is it the person
that found me and reached out to me and
now they know where i work is this going
to is this going to be the moment in
2015 the nevada attorney general's
office pushed the legislature to pass
the revenge porn law the person acted
with the intent to annoy harass
terrorize or alarm the person who is in
the photo senior deputy attorney general
laura tucker testifying before a
legislative committee that year what
were you thinking
that the state statute should save for
penalties what i was hoping for and what
i think the law does ultimately achieve
is give us the ability to have something
to point to to say
you know this this was a violation of
our laws but a sentence or a plea isn't
up to the attorney general's office it's
up to prosecutors and judges
in amick's case even though prosecutors
had accused him of sharing those
intimate images he agreed to a deal with
a new charge attempted unlawful
dissemination of an intimate image one
gross misdemeanor charge one year of
probation i've like completely just went
silent on social media because i
feel so
taken advantage i just feel so
dirty from it all that i just don't want
any part so i'd rather be invisible the
judge also ordering amick to stay off
social media for a year something his
ex-girlfriend has chosen to do chosen to
she says because of someone else's
actions so did this law work
no absolutely not that's what's the
point of it if it's not changing and
it's not helping any of the victims
the clark county district attorney's
office declined an interview for our
story but said there were issues with
evidence in the case and that like with
every case they could have taken it to
trial to a jury and then lost everything
denise and brian i also reached out to
the judge who presided over that plea
deal giving donald amick probation and a
court spokesperson told me that it would
be quote inappropriate for him to
comment on that matter all right so then
it sounds like do the judges have some
sort of discretion when it comes to
sentencing these cases so a plea deal
like this one no but a lot of times you
know in a murder case a judge might say
or a prosecutor might agree to a plea
deal of like eight to twenty year
sentence and the judge can pick in that
range so there was no leeway here
because of that deal where they said
you'll get probation for that attempted
charge
david if there was no deal what would
the sentence have been so this is a
category d felony that revenge porn
law
so that would have been at a maximum of
four years in prison with a fine but
when the ag's office tried to push this
through seven years ago they actually
wanted to be a category c felony which
would be a little more time in ten
thousand dollars but as we see here
anything can be pleated down and it's
really up to lawyers and prosecutors and
sometimes like we saw here the judge has
no say in what happens wow great
reporting david thank you thank you